oh [__] is going down [__]
you
oh [__] I don't give a [__] about heaps
snow sleet rain I don't give a [__]
we're smoking tonight
looks like 115 it don't matter after 92
pitches your nutsack I sweat you
[__] dripping you just wait to walk
home so you could wipe your [__] nut
sack and the crack between your nuts
it's a beautiful bear but inside I went
to jujitsu I met some [__] the Stroop
for [__] a little coffee and that was
it I don't need to be outside [__] these
[__] him in the house in the
air-conditioner like a doctor [__]
sanding my feet the understanding but
enough is enough
you got a slip outside from time to time
and do a little good so looks and who
better than you [__] savages uncle
Joey you know I enjoy the way you've
been off day listen guys it was Monday I
had a different agenda today but doesn't
[__] matter you know why don't matter
cuz uncle Joey's here now that's it grab
your ball salute the [__] Flag powder
his nutsack we're here [__] kiss that
that wants to call me now all day I'm
sitting there like patients on a [__]
monument I'm doing a periscope I'm
smoking a number with my goombazz and
this [__] wants to call me now
and tell me about whatever the [__] he's
got his sake
either pick up the phone and shoot
yourself and I'm saying it in my world
if you don't pick up the phone I move on
to the [__] next one we gotta go we
gotta hit to do and people to
[__] see
you can see the beads of sweat coming
down with every inhale but I don't give
a [__] I'm working that diaphragm I'm
kind of put the pieces together you're
there just like that I found my [__]
stick them my wife used it to [__]
make grit and believe them we ate meat
with THC particles I love my wife that's
why you gotta use your [__] coconut
from time to time
oh yeah
you could smell the stars of death
coming out of my armpits and out of my
feet and love and I'm sweating that
[__] THC on it but white sounds oh I
came home my [__] socks were yellow
you understand that's when you know it's
[__] hot out our second
all right listen I don't know what to
tell you I don't know what you're living
I don't know what the [__] yet all I
know is what Matt flame is doing thing
we're going deep
I totally we gonna find stars there's
nothing like [__] sweating and being
strong you know what's going on
but let's do this one more before I
[__] meltdown here oh yeah I lost
some [__] weight today long - Joey
looking looking handsomer than ever like
skips cop to do it anyway the [__] you
think at the moment
look at that
always working the [__] that looks like
dr. beliefs house anyway my eyeballs
they're getting that they [__] get
man
one more headband I'll set you loose
another [__] magnet
I just wanted to tag it with you check
them away and let you know I still got
you I got you you got me we got each
other that's all you need to [__]
know
come are you gonna work and keep your
eyes open you'll make your goals you do
your jump and Jack's gonna be happy so
we got a pouty ignites for an extra
towel some undies you gotta get in there
and beside that guess what [__]
our little meeting worked that's when
you know when you're meeting his work
everybody's happy
they do that the [__] hospitals are
together
Li's alone sweating profusely
he's [__] jet Dousman leave the window
open you'll feel the breeze hit the
breeze of [__] depth that's the only
breeze bang out the egg conditions [__]
the electronics you understand I got air
conditioners for the air conditioners I
have fallen gone back up swamp coolers
[__] how praises I will [__] around
you understand I don't believe in
[__] sweat like that sit in your
living room I gotta get the [__] out of
here
it's beautiful man it's [__] naturism
take your [__] nature shove it up
your ass
I like free I'm gonna sniffling my
[__] nostrils my Midnight's that I'd
be [__] around the freer you guys got
me on the road so when I smoke what are
you gonna do the [__]
it's Monday night there's no football
this little baseball I don't know I
don't even know when Nick suppose he's
in Holland yelling [__] screaming I
said I'm gonna let you [__] go
doing three or four [__] poison stops
you guys know and I'm the person ceviche
inside but Tara
look at that
we'll get that
keep smoking you see me right now send
them messages I'm suddenly smoke signals
I'm getting back to you through [__]
house Moses [__] podcast tomorrow
night 8 o'clock stoned to the gills be
ready around with your [__] Batman
cable and I don't give a [__] what you
gotta do
I enjoyed this little tape timetable you
[__]
I gotta go inside gotta get in the air
condition I'm a fat [__] you know how it
goes no disrespect I love you
[__] with all my heart
I gotta get an air conditioner for the
[__] balcony here that I'll make a
comeback all right I love you guys
tomorrow night 8 o'clock tomorrow
morning we'll make it together
my lapses or do choke me after to our
footing either I love you guys stay
black uncle Joey's got your back always
or if they didn't get my mic that I
being a liar they didn't get my mother
yeah pull my finger and go around my I
love your [__] stay black with
Joey gotcha